they are the not-so-silent minority
voted in the referendum but still
insisting that their voices be heard
above the din of political arguments it
was a march of the mostly mild-mannered
middle class many unfamiliar with street
protests but motivated by the muddle
that brexit negotiations has become up
to tears dismiss them as ramona's or
worse you know the brexit ears will say
this is the losers watch that's fine but
I think they're the losers really and
we're all gonna be losers in the end
things carry on the way they are yeah we
can just see it's one disaster after
another it's a complete mess of the
whole thing the ode to joy' was a little
mournful at times but there was stiff
competition for the wittiest banner
protestors dismissive of the direction
taken by some of the country's leading
political figures and some questioning
why the leader of the Opposition wasn't
leading the March demonstrations are
usually aimed at shifting government
policy but there's no chance of a second
vote if they can't convince labour to
commit to it politicians can't be
trusted to make the right decision a
prime minister can't even get a deal
through her cabinet in those
circumstances let the British public for
the first time have a say on the arc
current all the negotiations were the
option of state in the EU many of those
weren't old enough to vote in the
referendum but now want their say on
their future but there were older voters
too claiming their bricks to tear
counterparts had been deceived and how
long it was going to take to unpick it
all and they will say that's a really
patronizing attitude they knew exactly
what they were going
none of us knew I didn't know I had no
idea was going to lead to this I had no
idea after two years we would have got
nowhere as the crowds shuffled their way
towards Westminster it became clear that
this was one of the biggest marches of
recent years the organizers claiming it
topped half a million people the numbers
helped by unseasonal blue skies warm
weather and a non-threatening
kid-friendly atmosphere is growing
evidence from surveys that enormous
numbers of people are seriously alarmed
about where exits happening it's very
clear that there is no brexit legal
available that only specs of the
position we have at the moment
today the March went beyond party
political labels with conservative MPs
among the speakers people who voted a
porter night would have been greeted
with derision by brexit ears but right
now the big number which dictates to
resumes policy is the seventeen point
four million who voted to leave the EU
in woods Sky News Westminster